le premier j'ai jamais jeter sucre est
impressionné par ce que la police on les
voit quand même comme à la canton comme
un enfant comme les gens qui sont là
pour la sécurité pour défendre et
c'était que c'est mon premier rapport
avec des policiers et s'était pas du
tout remerciement quand j'avais 14 ans
je me rappelle j'avais une bicyclette
était partie faire des courses je
m'étais arrêtée à un feu rouge et il
m'avait contrôler pouvoir civil et
n'était pas volée ou quoi demander
est-ce que j'étais connu des forces de
l'ordre et à partir de ce moment là je
me suis dit à 13 ans quand même être
connus des forces de l'ordre
pour moi ça y est pas etes-vous connus
des forces de l'ordre
ça franchement c'est ça que même une
gifle quoi c'est qui je me suis dit
c'est ses outrances comme qu'on
m'insulte parce que je suis noir
forcément j'ai su que des services de
police ont pas généraliser à tous les
policiers à tous les contrôles
mais c'est vrai que il ya toujours une
fois policiers par équipage qui cassent
regard en tout cas qui veut en dire
beaucoup et qui cherche quand même la
confrontation sont au dessus de nous
quand les policiers vous parlez vous
parlez d'un air très haute à l'allemande
de responsables précisent se faire
contrôler comme ça sur la place publique
pour rien je n'aime pas le mot c'est
même pas une bonne image pour nous c'est
tout ça c'est une humiliation en fait
souvent il se passa j'ai avec mon groupe
de potes on parle et une voiture de
police à coup tu es tranquille moi
tranquille contraire d'un coup et 15 à
15 km est en baisse la vitre et nous
regardons les regards une espèce de
tension sans l'assentiment de m
c'est vraiment ce comme je disais deux
gangs rivaux presque qui sont la
population et les policiers qui
s'affrontent presque entre un regard ou
des gestes violents
en fait il nous rabaisse parce qu'il
sait qu'il est chez nous nous devant la
loi c'est dur il va nous parler de
manière à pour que nos chaunu parle mal
plus après et puis et puis s'en servir
contre nous avec les jeunes policiers
sont conflictuelles ce qui vient
d'arriver et qui doivent faire leurs
preuves et c'est assez conflictuel parce
que ils cherchent un peu un sans poser à
prouver aux autres que qu'ils vont pas
se laisser faire et c'est qu'ils ont des
épaules cours avec ceux qui ont un peu
plus de bouteille et d'expérience c'est
beaucoup plus facile de discuter avec
ils nous insultent
ga beauvois la bande de fils de [ __ ]
après il prend mon collègue
il le tire ils enchaîneront patate le
jette ses collègues le chum au sol et
après arrivé à moi il me tire me jette
au sol après une série de coups coups de
pieds coups pointent du doigt mais tu
sais que très rapidement tu peux pas en
avoir dans tes poches
si je le souhaite je comprends ce que je
veux dire on pas ouais ouais ce qu'on
prend on sature 4 est capable de m'en
mettre voilà tu comprends ce que je veux
dire je fume pas mais là tu peux très
rapidement en avoir donc quand tu me
parles et cetera soit pas trop autant et
c'est comme ça au procès tu peux rien
faire porter plainte contre un policier
c'est ça sert à rien ça s'arrête
franchement ses collègues on le défend
c'est l'avis rendu au quartier à barbès
un condor c'est normal pas trop les deux
trois fois dans ma jambe
non ma part une équipe différente c'est
tellement normal que en fait sa rentrée
et même dans nos cerveaux dans nos
moeurs c'est à dire que c'est impossible
de ne pas se faire contrôler pour rien
s'est imposé ce sont les appels on leur
dit qu'on a un problème je pense qu'ils
vont venir mais je veux dire si tous les
jours ils nous contrôlent et sur les
appels après ça c'est bizarre
et c'est comme si on le demande intérêts
qu'il nous fait du mal de venir nous
aider après il faut pas que je crois pas
que je m'arrête en tout cas faut pas
qu'ils m'arrêtent tout s'est compliqué
moi j'ai déjà couru parce que je voulais
pas juste vivre un conte drôle et sur ce
que ça mais encore de courir donc
heureusement si je suis pas attraper
j'ai pas tort mais si m'attraper que
j'ai couru pour rien même si j'ai rien
sur moi mais ma garde identité que je ne
vais pas de fiche de recherche que je
suis vraiment content mais totalement
clean le fait d'avoir couru déjà c'est
trop
c'est ça pour eux c'est le fait d'être
en tort d'avoir quelque chose à se
reprocher simplement que non c'est juste
j'en ai marre d'être contrôlé point j'en
ai marre de
vivre tout ça ça rend fois par semaine
un certain qu'on vous les voyez savez
c'est gratuit contrôlé par ton temps tu
arrêtes devant beaucoup de monde de
moncton identité presse et finira c'est
vous monsieur vous pouvez allez on vous
a construit comme ça